The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NEHA NARULA: Welcome back.
Today, we are going
to talk about forks.
So I think you guys have had
a guest lecture last week
from Alin Tomescu, who talked
about his project, Catena.
And one of the really
interesting things about Catena
is that he's trying to prevent
a server from equivocating.
So he's trying to keep
a server from being
able to say one answer to
some people and another answer
to another person.
That's kind of the goal of
this whole blockchain thing.
But there's actually
something really complex
that happens when we
start to change what's
happening in the
network, and we start
to change the software that's
happening in the network.
And so this lecture is
going to be about forks.
And I want you guys to feel
free to raise your hands
and ask questions during class,
because this stuff is actually
kind of non-intuitive sometimes.
So a blockchain is a chain of
blocks which have previous hash
pointers inside of them.
So a question-- can a block
point to two previous blocks
at the same time?
Anybody know the answer
to this question?
No, exactly, that
is the whole point.
There is exactly one
spot in the block header
for a previous hash block.
And so a block can only
point to one previous block.
A single block cannot point
to two previous blocks.
However, can this happen?
Can two different blocks point
to the same previous block
header?
Yes, yes, and this
happens all the time.
Now, part of the reason that
this happens all the time
is because the way
that blocks are
found in the bitcoin network
is completely probabilistic.
There are many
people who are trying
to find the next block
at the same time.
And it's entirely possible
that two different miners
will get lucky in
a time period that
is within the time it takes
for a block to get gossipped
around the network.
And so, totally, two people
can find the same block
at the same time.
This is actually
what's known as a fork.
And you can kind of see why.
We have a fork in
the chain right here.
But what does it
really mean when
there's a fork in the chain?
I just told you that
this is something
that happens all the time.
And these cryptocurrency
networks seem to keep running.
They seem to be keep going.
So perhaps it's not
as bad as it seems,
even though it seems
to be violating
one of the major tenets
of what a blockchain is.
Well, it is kind
of bad, actually,
because when you have
these two blocks here,
is there anything that makes
one the right blockchain
over the other blockchain?
Just if this is one
blockchain right here,
and this is another
blockchain right there,
how is one supposed to
distinguish between this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The one
with the most work.
NEHA NARULA: The one
with the most work,
OK, that's a great sort of
way of thinking about it.
What if they have similar
amounts of proof of work.
Then what?
AUDIENCE: The one
that's accepted
by the majority of the network.
NEHA NARULA: The
one that's accepted
by the majority of the network.
How do we know which
one is accepted
by the majority of the network?
It gets extended, OK, great.
So that's a really good
way of looking at it.
Before we go into
what that means,
do people understand why if
this state were to persist
it would be a really
bad situation?
One thing that we
could have, given
that there's two blocks,
what that really means
is that we have two
versions of history.
We have two versions
of the ledger
if these two things
are not the same.
Different coins might be
spent on one side of the fork,
versus on the other
side of the fork.
In fact, the same coin might be
spent in two different people
on either sides of these forks.
And so over here, Alice might
be spending her coin to Bob.
Over here, Alex might be
spending that same coin--
and, remember, coins
can only be spent once.
Even if Alice has
other coins, she
specifies which
coin she's spending.
Alice might spend that
coin over to Carol.
And so if Bob sees this,
he thinks he got paid.
If Carol sees this, she
thinks she got paid.
And we violated one of
the fundamental tenets
of the blockchain, which is
not to double spend coins.
You can't create
money out of nowhere.
If these two things
would persist,
if we don't resolve
this fork somehow,
then we literally have
two different versions
of the same currency.
This is kind of as
though I took the money
in my pocket, my dollar
bill, and I xeroxed them all,
and managed to convince some
people that the Xerox was also
real.
This is the exact
same thing as what's
happening when you have
these two things persist.
OK, so how do we fix it?
Well, which is the right one?
And just given what I've
shown you right here,
it is not clear which
is the right one.
And like I also said,
this happens all the time
in the bitcoin network
because the bitcoin network
is probabilistic.
So the way that people figure
out which one is the right one
is they wait.
They wait and see which
side gets extended.
And by the nature
of probability,
one side is going to eventually
win out, and get extended
more often than the other side.
It's very unlikely for
two forks to randomly sort
of probabilistically exist
at roughly the same way
for the same amount
of time for very long.
Now, as someone said,
you might look at this.
How do you distinguish
between these two things?
There is this common idea
that in blockchains we
take the longest chain.
Longest is a little bit
misleading actually.
It's not the longest chain.
It's the heaviest work chain.
So we pick the chain that
has the most proof of work
on it, even if that
happens to have
a smaller number of blocks.
Usually that's not the case.
That's not what happens.
The reason for
that-- does anyone
know why we take the heaviest
chain instead of the longest
chain?
AUDIENCE: So that nobody
can cheat and lower
the level of difficulty.
NEHA NARULA: Right, so it's
not very easy to do this.
But over time,
someone could slowly
decrease difficulty
level, and then
create a nice, really long
chain with many low difficulty
blocks, and then say, hey,
I've got the longest chain.
I have the most
number of blocks.
Despite the fact that your chain
has more proof of work on it,
you should all take my chain.
And they could do that
with less than a majority
of the hash power.
Now, this is not
easy attack to do.
But it is a possible attack.
And so that's why we take
the heaviest chain, which
represents the most hash power
in the system, the majority
of the system.
So forks happen all the time.
Forks are normal.
The way that people
who see forks decide
which side of the
fork to use, is they
check and see which one
has the most proof of work,
the heaviest proof of work.
Now, one thing
that's kind of cool,
is, as you probably learned
about two classes ago,
even SPV nodes,
even clients, can
tell which chain has
the most proof of work
simply by looking at the
headers, the block headers.
They can see what
the difficulty is.
And they can measure
for themselves
which side of the chain
has the most proof of work.
They don't even need
all of the chain.
So this is a nice
property of light clients,
is that they can download
all of the block headers
and immediately tell
which side of a fork
has the most proof of work.
Great, we call the block
that ends up-- so what
do we do with this block?
Does anyone know what actually
happens with this block?
Anybody?
OK, so this book is
basically abandoned.
This block is just left.
It exists.
It points into the chain.
That's great.
In bitcoin, in particular,
it's meaningless.
It doesn't mean anything.
Every transaction
that was in that block
is not considered
to have happened.
So those transactions
need to be replayed
on the chain that ends up
being the longest chain.
And this happens, like
I said, all the time.
We call that block an orphan,
because it doesn't have anyone.
It's kind of the
wrong way around.
I mean, I think of
this as a child.
But, whatever, this block
doesn't have a parent.
But we call those
blocks orphans.
And, again, remember,
we pick the side
of the chain that ends up
having the most proof of work.
Now, we draw these figures
in two different ways.
Sometimes we draw the
figures like this,
like there's this blockchain
that exists out there,
that is written down, and that
everyone is sort of looking at.
There's one blockchain.
But this isn't a
logical representation.
In reality, there are many,
many, many, many different
blockchains.
In fact, every
node in the system
has its own version
of the blockchain.
And it's what those
nodes are doing together
that ends up deciding what
the blockchain actually is.
So if these are nodes that are
running the bitcoin protocol,
and when I say nodes,
what's the difference
between a miner and a node?
AUDIENCE: Nodes
verify transactions,
but miners push blocks.
NEHA NARULA: Exactly,
so miners actually
create blocks in the system.
Miners have write access
to the blockchain.
They actually
produce new blocks.
People think a lot about
what the miners are,
and what the miners can do.
And there's a lot of game theory
thinking about the miners.
And, oh, what if they collude,
but the hash power does this?
And sometimes we forget that
nodes in the bitcoin network
are actually incredibly
important too,
because it's the nodes
in the bitcoin network
that are now creating blocks.
And, to be clear,
someone could be a miner
and a node at the same time.
They're distinct roles.
The same entity could certainly
run a node and be a miner.
But nodes are doing
something really important
as well, which is they're
reading all of the blocks.
And they're deciding which
side of a fork to take,
and which blocks to accept and
which blocks not to accept.
So let's say that these
are all bitcoin nodes.
And this is what the blockchain
looks like right now.
And we've used this
figure multiple times.
Every block has a previous
hash, which acts as a pointer
to the previous block.
Every block has a
set of transactions.
And every block
has a nonce, such
that when you take the
hash of the block header,
you end up with something
that has a sufficient number
of leading zeros.
It has valid proof of work.
So let's say that this is the
state of the system right now.
And then, we see this
new block come along.
So what happens here is that a
miner has produced this block,
and has sent it out over
the bitcoin network.
They've started gossiping
the block around the bitcoin
network.
And so every one of these nodes,
hopefully, will eventually,
if they're well connected,
will see this block.
They're going to see the
block at different times.
And they're each going to
make an independent decision
about the block.
So every node is going
to decide when it sees
this block what to do with it.
And there's basically two
things it can do with it.
One, it can add it to
its own local version
of the blockchain.
And number two,
it can reject it.
Does everyone see why that is?
So sure, every node is
maintaining this local copy
of a blockchain.
There is no single,
global copy that everyone
is referring to physically.
There's no single database
running the blockchain.
Every node has its own local
copy of the blockchain.
Every node is making its
own local decisions about
whether or not a block is
valid, and about whether or not
it's going to add that
block to its own local copy
of its blockchain.
So the way that the
node decides this
is that it has a set
of validation rules.
So it has its own set of
rules, which are specified
by the bitcoin protocol.
And it checks that block against
its set of validation rules.
So every node,
every bitcoin node,
is constantly validating,
constantly validating blocks.
Here are just some of
the validation rules.
And we've talked about a lot
of these sort of off and on
during the class.
So first of all, there's
a max block size.
And the way that this
works is if at any point
you fail one of these validation
rules, you reject the block.
So first, the block has to be
smaller than this variable max
block size.
At the moment, max block
size is set to 1 megabyte.
Every single transaction in
the block also has to be valid.
And what does that mean?
Well, it needs to be
formatted a certain way.
And it also means that when
we concatenate the script pub
key and the script sig
together, and then run that
through the
interpreter to evaluate
the script on the stack,
it ends up returning true.
And if at any point, any
transaction-- and not just
any transaction, any
input in any transaction,
does not satisfy this, we
reject the entire block.
Another thing that
each transaction
needs to satisfy if it's valid,
is if the transaction specifies
an end lock time,
than that end lock
time needs to be greater
than whatever is specified
in the transaction.
That transaction is now is
now far enough in the future
that it can be satisfied.
The block as a whole needs
to have valid proof of work.
So it needs to
have a nonce, such
that when you hash
the block header,
you end up with a hash that
has a certain number of leading
zeros.
And what's really interesting
is the protocol also
specifies exactly how many
leading zeros there need to be,
depending upon how many
leading zeros there have
been in blocks in the past.
There cannot be
any double spends.
So given the version of the
blockchain that I, as a node,
have, this better not be
double spending any outputs.
There are some rules
around what the block
can have as its timestamp.
It cannot be more than--
if I see a block that
has a timestamp that's
more than two hours in the
future from my own timestamp,
I will reject it.
And if it isn't after
some point that's
the median of the previous
block's timestamps,
then I'll also reject it.
And, of course, the block needs
to actually point to a block
that I've seen before.
And as a node, I
will keep around
blocks which have a
previous hash pointer that I
don't know about.
But I'm not going to
keep them around forever,
because that's a
potential Dos attack.
And in order for me to
actually insert this block
into my version
of a blockchain, I
need to know which
block to put it after.
Note also, note
what's not on here
is that it needs to be
the only block pointing
to a previous block.
I'll keep around multiple
blocks at the same level
until I have some sense of
which one is going to win out,
because of the
probabilistic nature
of maybe this block I'm
seeing is not going to end up
being part of the blockchain.
Maybe it's going
to be an orphan.
So these validation
rules are what
are called consensus critical
rules in the bitcoin network.
And what that means is that if
you want to tweak these rules,
if you want to
change them, then you
may end up changing which
blocks nodes will accept,
and which blocks
nodes won't accept.
Now, something that's kind
of interesting to note here
is that the entire script
interpreter in bitcoin
is consensus critical.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you reduce
the amount of transactions,
does that reduce the size
of the blocks as well?
NEHA NARULA: Yes, it can.
Yes, so you can
definitely have a block--
so that's a great
question actually.
So let's say that we had a
block that was half a megabyte.
What would nodes do?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I think an
advantageous miner would
potentially process it faster.
NEHA NARULA: That's true.
What would you as a node do.
If you're running the bitcoin
protocol as it exists today,
and it has the
following set of rules,
and I hand you a block
that's half a megabyte,
what would you do?
You would say OK, exactly,
because the rule that I
specified here just
says the block has
to be less than 1 megabyte.
It didn't say it has to
be greater than anything.
And is half a megabyte
less than 1 megabyte?
Yes, so you're going
to pass the checks.
And you're going to
accept the block.
AUDIENCE: Is that a good
thing for miners, so
maybe remove the transactions
from a potential block,
because they want to
process it faster?
NEHA NARULA: Sure, so the
question is, should miners
remove transactions
from a block,
or perhaps not put
transactions in a block,
because it seems like they could
process a small block faster
than a large block, right?
So that is very true.
Miners, if there are
fewer transactions,
they have fewer
things to verify.
So they can check and see
if the book is valid faster.
However, the fewer transactions,
the fewer the transaction fees.
And so the less the miner
will earn from the block.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And also, the energy
put in, most of it mining,
is like mining the block,
not actually verifying.
NEHA NARULA: Yeah.
So verifying transactions is
nowhere near as CPU-intensive
as it is to actually
find the nonce
and produce the proof of work.
However, miners should
verify transactions
before even starting
that process.
And so if a miner didn't
verify transactions,
they would get a head start
on the proof of work process.
So there's that sort of balance.
And, in fact, I think we've
talked about this in this class
before, there have
been times in history
where things have happened that
have shown that miners actually
haven't been verifying blocks.
They'll just mine on whatever.
It's caused some problems.
And they ended up
losing a lot of money
because they should have
been verifying blocks.
Great.
So these rules are what are
called consensus critical.
They are the rules that
each node independently
uses to decide
whether or not they're
going to accept the block.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you
talk about nodes,
you talk about SPDs, right?
NEHA NARULA: No.
I'm not talking about SPDs
when I talk about nodes.
I'm actually talking
about full nodes.
So I'm talking about
nodes that are holding
onto the entire bitcoin
blockchain, that
are looking at every
block, every transaction.
AUDIENCE: So the
difference between a miner
and and a node are [INAUDIBLE]?
NEHA NARULA: A miner--
yeah, they're distinct roles.
So a miner is running this
proof of work algorithm
to try to find--
to produce blocks.
A full node does
not write blocks.
It doesn't create new blocks.
It receives blocks, and
then validates them, or not,
and adds them to its local
copy of the blockchain.
A miner might also be
running a full node.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Miners should
be running full nodes.
NEHA NARULA: Yeah,
they should be.
But it's not clear that that
happens, for the reasons
we were talking about before.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: You can force
miners to [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: OK, so let's go
back to this image right here.
These nodes are all running
some version of the software.
They see this transaction.
And they say, yes, this looks
like a valid transaction to me.
And note that they have to--
or, sorry, block.
They look at this block.
Yes, this looks like
a valid block to me.
And note that they kind
of have to evaluate
that block with respect
to all of the other blocks
that it's seen.
No double spends, all of the
scripts eggs, the script pub
keys, work out correctly, it's
the right size, et cetera,
et cetera.
And then once it's decided
that that's all OK,
each node will independently
make the same decision
to add that block
to its blockchain.
So you can see here that
determinism is actually
really important.
It can't be the
case that there's
any randomness in this process.
It can't be the case
that sort of randomly,
depending on the time of
day, one node will decide
this is a valid
block, one node will
decide it's not a valid block.
That's not the greatest
situation to have happen.
We want this to be as
deterministic as possible.
We want them to all
independently arrive
at the same decision.
Great.
So this is how validation works.
This is what nodes do.
Major problem,
though-- sometimes,
we need to change
the validation rules.
Sometimes, we need to
upgrade the software.
I mean, software is
not a static thing.
The software that these
nodes are running,
there's going to be bugs.
There might be security
vulnerabilities.
We might want to
add new features.
And so we're going to want to
change the validation rules.
It's pretty much inevitable.
And, yet, given the
nature of the system,
we can't upgrade every
single node at the same time.
So I think a useful analogy
here, something to think about,
is actually browsers.
So web browsers-- right now,
a lot of people run Chrome.
But not everyone runs Chrome.
And Chrome actually
has auto update
where it will push
changes to your browser.
Google will automatically
upgrade you.
But the way the
browsers used to work
is that you didn't
always have auto update.
Or it would bother
you, and ask you
if you were OK with
auto updating before.
And people would say, I don't
deal with this right now.
I'm in the middle of something.
I don't want to auto
update my browser,
and have to restart
the whole thing.
And so what would
end up happening
is you'd have significant
numbers of people on very
different versions of browsers.
And this was kind of a
disaster for the internet,
because people who were
developing websites,
they wouldn't have
any confidence
that the majority
of their users,
or a significant
majority of their users,
had upgraded to
the new features.
So they had to support all
these old versions of browsers.
And it was a nightmare.
So that's what we're dealing
with here in cryptocurrencies,
except it's even worse.
So you definitely cannot
guarantee that everyone will
upgrade their software
at the same time.
You can't guarantee
that everyone will even
upgrade ever.
And so the designers
of the software,
when you want to create a
new version of software,
you have to think really,
really carefully about it.
So let's say that we're
in this situation right
here, where these three nodes
are running V1 of the software.
The developers
have worked out V2.
V2 has some interesting
new features,
which slightly
changed the validation
rules about what a
node running V2 will
consider valid or invalid.
So now, when we see this new
block, and we ask the question,
is this block valid, these nodes
might make different decisions.
In particular, maybe the old
nodes will think it's valid.
Great, passes all
the validation rules.
I will append this
block to my blockchain.
And the new node will
not think it's valid,
and will say, garbage
block, fantastic.
I will not append this
block to my blockchain.
And what we end up
with when this happens
is we have two different
versions of history.
The nodes running the old
version of the software
think that there are four
blocks in the blockchain.
The nodes that are running the
new version of the software
have decided that
that block is invalid.
And they only have three
blocks in the blockchain.
So what does this mean?
First of all, is this like
the situation we saw before,
where if we just wait
for enough proof of work
this will sort itself out?
What do you guys think?
I'm seeing some people
shaking their heads.
And, yes, this situation is
different than the situation
we saw before,
because the situation
we saw before, all the nodes
still had the same validation
rules.
They just saw the blocks
in different orders,
or they got later, whatever.
All of that can be resolved by
looking at the proof of work.
Sometimes when this
happens, sometimes
when nodes are actually
running different versions
of validation
software, things can
be resolved by just
looking at proof of work.
But quite often,
actually, they can't.
And so in this situation,
what might happen
is another block comes along.
So this is a different
block than this one.
And this set of
nodes might decide
that this is the next
block in the blockchain,
whereas the blue nodes will
never, ever, ever validate
this block.
They will never decide
that this block is valid,
given the version of the
software they are running.
They will never
switch to a blockchain
that has this block
in it, even if it
has the most proof of work.
So I think this is a
really important point.
And I think it sort
of fundamentally
gets to why miners
don't actually
have as much power
in the system as one
might think that they do.
And the reason for that is that
the way bitcoin is designed
is that a node will never accept
a chain with a single invalid
transaction.
If, according to
its set of rules,
a single transaction is
invalid, it will completely
ignore that chain.
Doesn't matter if it has
the most proof of work.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
It's kind of intense.
It's kind of crazy, right?
Like, even if it has
mountains upon mountains
of proof of work,
it will completely
ignore that chain
because there's
something invalid about it.
So miners can mine
what they want.
But they better mine
within the validation rules
set of the economic
majority of the nodes.
Otherwise, those
nodes are all going
to ignore whatever they mine.
And their money is not
going to be worth anything.
Great.
So in this situation, we end up
with two different blockchains.
And we actually end up with
something quite irreconcilable,
unless we change the
software again, somehow.
And what we've ended up
with that's irreconcilable
is we now have a block over
here, and a block over here.
This node will never accept a
chain with this block in it.
And so we've got two
different blockchains.
So when this happens,
we call it a fork.
Now, the word fork can be used
to mean many different things
in software.
For example, you fork
a project on GitHub.
When you fork a
project on GitHub,
you might make changes to it.
This is a little bit different
because of the linearity
of history here.
When a fork happens
in a cryptocurrency,
in particular a sort of a fork
that can't easily be resolved,
that isn't just
going to, oh, one
side has more proof
of work, OK, great
we're all going to switch
to that other side.
When you have a fork
that can't be resolved
that easily then it's
actually a pretty big deal,
because like we
were saying earlier
we now have two versions of
history, two different versions
of money.
It's like I took the
dollar from my wallet,
and I photocopied it.
And now there's $2 where
there was only one.
So maybe you like
this kind of dollars.
Maybe you don't like
that kind of dollars.
We've basically taken
this entire network
that all sort of agreed on
what this form of money was,
and we've divided it into two.
So there's two
different kind of forks
that people will talk about
mostly in this industry.
But forking is actually much
more complicated than that.
You can't just
talk about forks as
in-- so the two
different kinds of forks
are soft forks and hard forks.
And I'm going to explain
what a soft work is,
versus a hard fork.
But, actually, that
delineation, it
gets much more nuanced because
different things happen
in a soft fork
versus a hard fork,
depending upon who's
decided to adopt the rules.
OK, so a soft fork--
a soft fork is a fork which
is backwards compatible.
So we have some rule set.
And under that
rule set you apply
that rule set to every
single possible one megabyte
chunk of data.
And we're going to end
up with some set of what
are valid blocks.
A soft fork is when you
add rules to the rule set,
such that the set of valid
blocks actually shrinks.
So what does that mean?
We had a whole bunch
of rules before.
Blocks have to be
less than 1 megabyte.
Transactions all
have to be valid.
It means that their scripts
certify, like validate,
under the certain
script interpreter,
et cetera, no double spends.
Let's take one of the rules
that's actually pretty simple,
which is that blocks have to
be less than one megabyte.
Let's say that I
change that to blocks
have to be less
than two megabytes.
Is that a soft fork?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NEHA NARULA: Oh, wow, there's
some actual dissent over this,
right?
OK, so someone who says
no, why is the answer no?
AUDIENCE: Because you have
something that is now accepted
that wasn't accepted before.
NEHA NARULA: Right, so
remember, valid blocks
before newly valid blocks
fit inside of this.
Now, someone who
said yes it's a soft
fork, why do you think that?
AUDIENCE: All blocks
still have less than two.
NEHA NARULA: Right.
So it's actually
not a soft fork.
And the reason that
it's not a soft fork
is because a block that is
1.75 megabytes, previously,
the old rule set, was invalid.
New rule set, it's valid.
But we just said everything
that's newly valid
has to fit inside
what used to be valid.
So a soft fork is restricting
the set of valid things.
You can think of it as
expanding the set of rules
that a block now
has to comply with.
So a feature of this is
that if you don't upgrade--
so V1 is the old rule software.
V2 is the new rule software.
If you don't upgrade,
you will continue
to see the new blocks as valid.
And this is actually
a very nice property,
because, remember what
happened over here,
we had this property where
the people on the blue side
were just never,
ever going to accept
one of these blockchains.
And if it were the case
that this were a soft fork,
the old side would never, ever--
well, if this sorry,
if it were the case
that this weren't a
soft work, the old nodes
would never accept
this new stuff.
So soft forks are really
nice, because they're
backwards compatible.
Old nodes will still see
the new blocks as valid.
They won't reject them.
If that chain gets a
ton of proof of work,
then the old nodes will happily
switch over to that chain.
So, what does that mean?
So let's say that the black
nodes are the old rules,
and the blue nodes are new
rules, new rule blocks.
And, again, we have to
look at this from two
different perspectives.
There are the people
creating the blocks.
And there are the people
reading the blocks.
And sometimes those
are the same people.
Sometimes, they're not.
So we're looking at blocks here.
So these are people who
are creating the blocks.
And, again, both of
these sets of people
might upgrade or not upgrade.
So we might have miners who
are following the old rules
and miners who were
following the new rules.
Then we might have
validating nodes
who are following the old
rules, and validating nodes who
are following the new rules.
And this is not even
talking about SPV yet.
OK, we're just
talking about miners.
And we're talking about nodes.
So let's say some of the miners
upgrade to the new rules,
but not all of the miners
upgrade to the new rules.
The miners who didn't
upgrade to the new rules
are going to continue
producing old rule blocks.
They're going to continue
producing V1 version blocks.
But if the majority of miners
upgrade to the new rules,
remember, the new rule
people have new rules.
So they have more restrictions
on the set of blocks
that they will accept.
So they might not see
that block as valid.
So they're never going to
accept that chain, because it
has invalid things in it.
Once you've upgraded,
you might no longer
accept the old chain as valid.
And so what's going
to end up happening
is something that looks
very much like the orphaning
situation that was
happening before,
where if the majority of
the hash powers, which
is over here, this chain is
going to keep going bigger.
These guys might keep trying
to produce old style blocks.
But they just keep
getting orphaned off.
It's actually like very much
in their economic interest
to hurry up and upgrade, so
they're not wasting hash power
on orphan blocks.
Are there questions
about soft forks?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are
soft forks also used
for changing software
other than validation?
NEHA NARULA: Yes,
that's a great question.
Are soft forks also used
for changing software other
than validation?
So we can certainly upgrade
more than just the validation
parts of the bitcoin software.
If it doesn't change the set of
blocks that would be accepted
or not accepted, we don't
even bother calling it a fork.
So let's say that we wanted to
change something about the peer
to peer network, or the way
that things are stored on disk,
or something like that.
We would see that
a change like that,
if it didn't change the set
of blocks that would have been
accepted or not accepted,
if after the change
a set of blocks accepted or
not accepted is the exact same,
we don't call that a fork, a
change that induces a fork.
It's only when the set of blocks
are accepted or wouldn't be
accepted are actually changed.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How often do updates
get pushed on the network?
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
How often do updates get
pushed on the network?
So Bitcoin is at
version 0.16 right now.
And 0.16 came out like
a week or two ago.
And I think it's sort of been
on the order of a couple months
between different
versions of Bitcoin.
Other cryptocurrencies
release more frequently.
Some release less frequently.
Some do forks very,
very regularly.
And we'll speak a
little bit about that.
But the software is pretty much
constantly getting updated.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in
practice, people are just
updating their versions?
NEHA NARULA: Yeah, so in
Bitcoin in particular,
Bitcoin does not have
an auto update function.
So in order to run the new
version of the software,
you have to decide
that you're going
to run the new version
of the software.
Or there might be a way to
decide to turn auto update on.
I can't remember.
But the point is that
they try to leave it
in their user's hands.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How are
versions created?
So if you like on the GitHub,
there are a ton of features,
and sometimes they're
pushed forward.
Is there a subreddit, where
they're like, OK, version?
NEHA NARULA: OK, how
are versions created?
It's actually very similar to
any other software project,
where the people who work
on the software project
get together, and decide
which pull requests are going
to be part of the new version.
So, yes, at some
point, they're just
like, new version, release.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do software get
released as updated versions?
NEHA NARULA: Yes, soft
forks are definitely
released as updated versions.
So that's a great question.
I think not every version
has a soft fork in it.
But if there is a soft
fork, it will definitely
be a new version.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why can't
this black miner
not just look at the
version in the blue block
and decide not to?
NEHA NARULA: Because
it's not a blue block.
So you're talking
about here, right?
OK, so the nodes are
running different software.
And then a block
comes along that--
ideally, yes the block would
have a version number in it
that specifies which
version of the software.
And this is a very useful
field in the block header.
But that's not really--
so what it has a
different version?
AUDIENCE: If it's
lower than mine--
sorry, higher than mine,
then I don't do it.
Then I won't update first.
NEHA NARULA: What do
you mean by don't do it?
You mean, you ignore it?
AUDIENCE: No, I
[INAUDIBLE] myself,
because I see that a higher
version is in circulation.
NEHA NARULA: So that
would be one way
of running the network, which
is if I ever see anything that
indicates that there's
newer software out there,
I just realize I'm old,
and that I need to update.
I think that Bitcoin simply
made a different design
decision, which was that older
nodes should still be able to--
because think about nodes
that were sort of set it
and forget it, they're
out there running.
One tenant that
is absolutely true
is that users will not upgrade.
They will not all upgrade.
It just won't happen.
You will have old versions
of software running.
And given that you will have old
versions of software running,
I think it's a question
as to whether or not those
nodes should still be
a part of the network,
or whether you just
want to slice them off
because they're not
running the latest version.
And I think in
Bitcoin, they want
those nodes to still be
a part of the network.
They want people to be able to
make the active decision not
to upgrade.
Tadge actually, I think is still
running 0.13, or some older
version of Bitcoin.
Still works great.
He can still validate
transactions totally fine.
OK, so we just talked
about soft forks.
And I think the important thing
to remember about soft works
is that soft works are
backwards compatible.
We also talked about an example
that is not a hard fork, which
is if we decided that we
wanted to allow blocks that
were less than two
megabytes, instead of less
than one megabyte.
And so a 1.75 megabyte
of block appears.
That is not a soft work.
What if we changed
the rule to say
that, instead of only
accepting blocks that
are less than one
megabyte, we're
only going to accept blocks that
are less than half a megabyte.
Is that a soft
work or hard fork?
AUDIENCE: Soft fork.
NEHA NARULA: That's a soft work.
The reason that
that's a soft fork,
is because a block that is
less than half a megabyte
was also still less
than one megabyte.
So it's still valid under
the old set of rules.
So if the change made here was
now we want smaller blocks.
So we're only going
to take blocks that
are less than half a megabyte.
That's fine.
Everyone will still see
this chain as valid.
This is still
backwards compatible.
Just because your blocks
are 300 kilobytes now
doesn't mean that
they violate a rule.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask one last
question in relation to that?
So what happens if I
want to do something
with the old version,
and [INAUDIBLE]..
And they realize, wow,
I love [INAUDIBLE]..
NEHA NARULA: Right,
so what happens
to all the previous
stuff in my chain, right?
Now, ideally, the
way that the rules
would be setup, the new rules,
is that they would take effect
sometime in the future.
So you wouldn't
apply those rules
retroactively to the things that
you already put into the chain,
because then you just
throw away all history.
And that would be
kind of a bummer.
Instead, you say,
after this block,
we are only going to
accept blocks that
are less than half a megabyte.
AUDIENCE: So what happens
if after that block,
so a majority of miners
are running old software.
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: We'll
get into that.
We'll get into what happens when
the majority, versus minority,
of different parts of
the ecosystem decide
to adopt the change, versus
not adopt the change.
But first, we're going
to talk about hard forks.
What is a hard fork?
A hard fork is not
backwards compatible.
And so a hard fork
is a fork where,
if this was the
old set of rules,
under the new set of
rules you actually accept
more blocks than you would
have accepted before.
So just to be clear,
under the new rules,
you might produce a block,
which a node running
under the old rules will reject.
This is not
backwards compatible,
because any chain that has
this new type of block in it
will not be accepted by any
of the old nodes, full stop.
It doesn't matter about
proof of work at all.
OK, so the thing
with hard forks is
that because they're not
backwards compatible,
they're a little crazier and
a little bit sort of harder
to manage in your network.
Because if you do a hard fork
and not everyone upgrades,
you might end up with two
chains, possibly forever.
If we assume that those nodes
are not going to upgrade--
and let's say they're not
upgrading because there's
no one really maintaining them.
Then they're not going
to upgrade in the future.
And they're not going to
upgrade to a change that
might fix what's going on here.
They're just going to keep
doing their old time thing.
Then with a hard
fork, these nodes
are never going to
accept the new blocks.
It doesn't matter what the
proof of work is on that chain.
So hard forks
versus soft works--
hard forks, as I keep stressing,
are not backwards compatible.
Guess what?
A fork can be a hard fork and
a soft work at the same time.
Yay.
Super confusing,
actually, because you
can both restrict
the set of rules
and expand the set of
rules at the same time.
Basically, it means it's a new,
overlapping, but not entirely
inclusive or not inclusive,
set of rules, very unfortunate.
In fact, most things
should actually
be both, to avoid
some of the things
that I'm going to
show you in a minute.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But then for
all useful purposes,
isn't it just a hard
fork, because that
means some nodes won't
be inside the blocks.
NEHA NARULA: For
all useful purposes,
it's not just a hard fork.
Let me see if I can--
The reason that it's
not just a hard fork--
this is something that requires
a little bit more thought.
It's not just a hard fork.
But I will think about how
to explain this, and perhaps
say something on this.
Or, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: It is.
But he's asking, isn't
that just a hard fork?
And it's not just a
hard fork, because I
think old nodes will
do something different.
Ah, OK, so there's two reasons
why it's not just a hard fork.
One is because of reorgs.
So different things will happen
as the majority of hash power
starts to accept or
not accept the change,
whether or not all nodes
will switch over or not.
But if it's both a
hard and a soft work,
they will never switch over.
But I think the question
is whether old nodes can
even still function.
So I think one way
to use combination
hard and soft works
is to actually stop
the old nodes from being
able to have blocks at all.
Like, you design
things in such a way,
that given a majority of
hash power moves over,
they're just going to
end up with nothing.
But this is a really
good question.
And we should go into
more detail on this.
And I will try to figure out
a way to get that to you guys.
OK, so who controls forks?
Yes?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The developers.
NEHA NARULA: OK, the
developers, which I didn't even
write down as a note here.
OK, do the Bitcoin
developers control forks?
Who thinks yes?
You're not even
raising your hand.
Who thinks no?
Determines whether or not a
fork is going to go through.
There's the Bitcoin
developers, who are actually
writing the software,
and who also
have a lot of influence
in the system,
because presumably they
understand it really well
if they're writing software.
So they can write some
software, and decide
that they want to do a fork.
Does that mean that the
fork is going to go through?
No, certainly not,
everyone can ignore them.
And there have been
situations in the past
where everyone ignored
them for quite a long time,
and argued about it, and
didn't push a fork through.
Well, miners are the ones who
actually create the blocks.
Are they the ones
who control forks?
I see a very strong
head shake no.
Why do you shake your head?
AUDIENCE: So if
the miners decide
to change what types of
blocks they're putting out,
they can do that.
But the nodes that are
actually validating it,
no one can say they're
not going to accept it.
NEHA NARULA: Very true.
So as we saw before, there
are times when nodes will not
accept a chain no matter
how much proof of work
it has on it.
I think that's a very
common misunderstanding.
The nodes run their
own validation rules.
And so if I'm running a
node, I can run whatever
validation rules I want.
And I can decide what
chain is the one that
aligns with my interests.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you're
doing a hard fork,
and you are
accepting new blocks,
and they just never mined any
blocks with those new rules.
NEHA NARULA: Exactly.
So there's certainly incentives
in many different directions.
If all the miners decided
to go to one side,
then I'm a full node with
my side of validation rules
who has no new blocks.
Great, what am I going to do?
How am I going to
make transactions?
spend my money?
Also, let's say all the
miners don't go to one side,
but most of them do, and most of
the nodes go to the other side.
Then what am I going to do?
Who's going to listen to me?
Who's going to trade with me?
Who's going to take the
coins on my side of the fork?
So I guess that's just to
say that it's complicated.
There's the developers.
There's the miners.
There's nodes.
There's the users who
determine the economic value
of these tokens, and
which side they think
is more valuable
or less valuable.
And we've seen this
happen with lots
of cryptocurrencies
multiple times.
And it's kind of exciting.
So Bitcoin has forked
multiple times.
And every time
it's forked so far,
it has created a whole
new version of the coin.
So it's been like a
pretty serious hard fork.
And so now, in
addition to Bitcoin,
there's Bitcoin Cash, Bitcoin
Gold, Bitcoin Diamond.
Ethereum also has fought.
In Ethereum's case, they
tried to take along everyone
with them.
And so the hard
fork was supposed
to be an upgrade to Ethereum.
But some people
decided they didn't
want to go along with it.
So there's Ethereum Classic.
And there's Ethereum.
Both of them have value.
So it's really unclear
who controls forks.
So now, let's talk about
hash rate and forks.
So nodes are pretty--
OK, what nodes will do is they
have a set of validation rules.
If a block validates under
their set of validation rules,
they will accept it.
And if all the blocks validate
under their validation rules,
they will accept the chain
that those blocks are on.
And if there are two
different chains where
all the blocks validate
under their validation rules,
they'll take the one with
the heaviest proof of work.
That's what nodes do.
So heaviest proof of work
is clearly kind of important
here, if both sides
of a fork validate.
So if both sides of
a fork validate--
so we have to think about this
from the perspective of nodes
who upgrade to the new
software, and nodes who
don't upgrade to new software.
So it might be worth it
to try to kind of write
this down a little bit.
So we have the old rule
nodes, and the new rule nodes.
And let's just talk about
one kind of work for now.
Now, let's say less than
50% of the miners upgrade.
And let's say greater than
OK, so let's use
this chart, as we're
kind of trying to
reason about what's
going to happen in the ecosystem
for soft works and hard works.
So what happens if a soft fork
does not obtain more than 50%
of the hash rate?
So we've got the old rules.
We've got nodes.
Some nodes have upgraded.
Some nodes haven't upgraded.
Less than 50% of the
miners have upgraded.
So the old rule chain
is going to be longer,
because they're going
to continue mining
on the old rules.
By the way, sometimes
they don't ignore things
with the new rules.
Sometimes they do.
It's very complicated.
But let's just pretend right now
that they are ignoring things
with the new rules, because
they haven't upgraded,
and they don't see that.
Or, sorry, they would see
the new rules as valid.
But the majority of the
hashing power is over here.
So what's going to happen?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The
benefits of the fork
aren't going to really be
useful much, because be there'll
be some blocks
with the new rules.
But the majority is just
not going to change.
NEHA NARULA: Right, so it kind
of depends on the soft fork.
So it depends on what the new
rule nodes think of old blocks.
If they think that old
blocks are still all valid,
then they're going to build
upon old blocks just fine,
because they think
they're valid.
If they think that old
blocks are no longer valid,
then they're going to try
to do their own chain.
But the majority of the hashing
power is with the old side.
So they're just going
to get reorged out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If it's a
soft fork, but they also
think all the blocks are
valid, how is it a fork at all?
NEHA NARULA: So
an example of this
is taking what was
an unused op code,
and now making it meaningful.
So it just so happens that
none of the old rule nodes
ever used this silly
unused op code.
Because they never
used it, they never
had any invalid
uses of the op code.
So the new nodes will
still accept old blocks,
because none of them
use this op code anyway.
But if they were to
use the new op code,
and they used it
as a no-op op code,
instead of what the
new rules are then
it would be an invalid block.
Does that make sense?
So you have to think
really carefully
about how you are
designing these upgrades
to your software.
You have to think
very carefully what
will happen to the old nodes.
What happens if 50% of the
miners take this thing?
Well, under the old rules,
was anyone actually using
this thing, that we
are now maintaining
must be used in a new way?
Or pay to script hash is a
good example of this as well.
Pay to script hash, technically,
looks like you're just
paying to a hash.
So old nodes will
see it, and say, OK,
if you can produce
a signature that
shows that this is valid,
blah, blah, whatever, whatever,
that's fine.
But nobody ever did that.
Nobody ever did that
in a way that was
meaningful under the new rules.
No one ever used it.
So all the old things will
still validate, simply
because no one ever
did anything that
was under the subset
of the new rules.
Sorry, this is very
kind of complicated.
So what we have here is that
if old rule blocks are still
valid, the software
will get reorged out.
So no fork there, no fork there.
You're just not
really going to end up
with stuff in the blockchain.
If old rule blocks
are now invalid,
then we're going to
end up with two chains.
Do people see why this is?
Because the new
rule people are not
going to accept any chain that
has an invalid thing in it.
So they're not
going to reorg out.
They are going to continue.
And they are going to
have their own chain.
And they're going to
ignore all of the blocks
on the other chain, which they
deem to be the invalid chain.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this the
case for Bitcoin Cash?
NEHA NARULA: No, it's not
the case for Bitcoin Cash.
It's actually the
case for something
called a user-activated
soft fork, which the bitcoin
community threatened to do
when the miners wouldn't
do a soft fork they
wanted them to do.
They said, fine, you miners
won't do the software
that we want you to do.
So, normally, people
don't like the situation.
So you don't want
this to happen.
So, normally, soft
forks are written such
that if you don't get 95%
of the miners to sign,
on the soft fork
never activates.
So that's the way that,
traditionally, soft works are
done in the Bitcoin ecosystem.
What does that mean?
It means 5.001%
of the hash power
can stop a soft fork
from going through.
So usually, things are
written in such a way
that you really want to
guarantee this two chain
thing never happens.
We see hash power
is kind of voting.
And if you can get
95% of the hash power
to agree with the soft fork,
then only will the soft fork
activate.
And the way that miners do this
is they signal in their block
headers that they are going
to adopt the soft fork.
And then the software is
usually programmed in such a way
that it looks at some sliding
window of block headers
to determine whether
95% of the hash power
has decided that they're
going to go along with it.
And it only activates
once that's the case.
So doing protocol
upgrades is really hard.
It's not a trivial matter.
You don't just push some code.
So usually, it's
the case that you
want to wait for a significant
majority of the mining power
to indicate support
for the soft fork.
And, by the way, they
can indicate support
without actually
running the soft fork.
This happens all the time.
But you want to wait
for significant support
from the mining
community before actually
activating the soft fork.
What happened recently
with something
called Segregated Witness,
which we'll talk about,
which was a soft fork to Bitcoin
to introduce new functionality
that the miners opposed, was
the community actually said,
forget it.
We are going to start
running the new rules.
We're going to ignore you.
We don't care what the majority
of the hash power does.
We are going to go ahead
and create this two chain
situation, and follow the
chain with the new rules.
Interestingly, this
actually worked.
I think it was like 80 plus
percent of the hash power
was not in favor
of the soft fork.
And the users managed to create
this kind of detente where they
forced everyone to go along
with what they wanted,
super interesting.
They had no actual way to vote.
It was entirely
sort of via Twitter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yes, so this
is one of the major reasons,
and I think some of
the strongest evidence,
that miners have nowhere
near as much power
as you actually think they
do in these ecosystems.
Certainly have power, and
part of the power they
have is to do what's
called an evil soft fork,
which I'm not going to
talk about in this class,
but I think we
probably should talk
about at some point in time.
OK, great.
Let's see.
OK, if the soft fork
is greater than 50%,
old rule blocks will follow the
new rule blocks automatically.
So we get soft fork successful.
We do not have two chains,
because these will simply
be orphaned and abandoned.
And, in fact, there's actually
pressure for the miners
to move over to the new rules
so that their blocks aren't
abandoned.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
making it easier
mine, are those
considered types of forks?
NEHA NARULA: It depends.
So the question is
around difficulty,
and the number of leading zeros
required in the proof of work.
That changes all the time.
There's a formula
which determines
what that number should be.
So, no, it doesn't
require a fork.
But if you want to change the
formula, that would be a fork.
Requiring more proof of
work would be a soft work.
Requiring less proof of
work would be a hard fork.
OK, now let's talk
about hard forks.
So what happens if
a hard fork doesn't
obtain 50% of the hash rate?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: It depends, again.
It depends on if the old
rule blocks are still valid.
So we're doing a hard fork.
We're changing the
set of valid blocks.
If blocks are still valid
under the old rules,
then we're going to end up
with a situation like this.
If old rule blocks
are still valid
according to the new rule
nodes, then the new rule nodes
will just follow along.
OK, so basically no
work happening here,
because the new rule nodes
are going to produce blocks.
They're not going to have
enough of the hash power.
And so they're not going
to be considered valid
by the other set.
So they're going
to end up following
along with the old rule nodes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Again, isn't the
whole point of a hard fork
that you're expanding the
set of things that are valid?
So aren't all old blocks going
to be valid in a hard fork?
NEHA NARULA: Not if it's
a combination hard fork,
soft fork.
So maybe I should
split this up into
whether or not
it's a combination
hard fork, soft fork, or not.
OK, so what happens if a hard
fork doesn't obtain greater
than 50% of the hash rate?
What's going to happen then?
AUDIENCE: We'll be
mining to the old rules.
NEHA NARULA: Yes, we're going
to end up with two chains.
This is going to have chain--
whatever, the point
is, there's going
to be an old chain
and a new chain.
The old nodes are never going
to accept the new nodes blocks.
And we're going to end up
with two chains forever.
And this has happened
multiple times.
Are there questions
about hard forks?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there ways for
the hard fork to make life
really difficult for
the smaller chain?
NEHA NARULA: Are there ways
for a hard work to make life
really difficult for
the smaller chain?
That is a good question.
I think it depends.
So there's multiple ways
to make life difficult.
I think what you're
asking is not,
what if the hard fork becomes
more popular and more people
decide to move over to it,
and abandon the smaller chain?
That's one way in which life
could be more difficult.
But another way that life
could be more difficult
is if the hard fork somehow made
the previous chain no longer
a productive chain to be on.
And I think that the primary
way that that would happen
would not actually
be a hard fork,
but would be a combination
hard fork, soft fork.
But there are definitely
ways for miners
to play with hard forks and soft
forks in such a way that-- see,
this is actually kind
of ideal in some ways.
This is like, OK, we disagree
on what the rules should be.
I want some new set of rules.
You don't want some
new set of rules.
Fine, let's just
split the ecosystem.
You guys go your way.
I'll go my way.
We'll have two different coins.
Life will be great.
What's kind of not
so nice is when
one side tries to coerce
the other side to go along,
which is kind of what a
greater than 50% soft fork is.
You're kind of
coercing the other side
to go along, because they
have no way of opting out.
And there are ways that miners
can make the side of the chain
with less harsh power
basically useless.
This is totally
something miners can do.
People talk about
it occasionally.
It just doesn't seem
like they figured out
that they can do it, or
they haven't tried to do it.
I don't know.
Maybe they don't want to do it.
I'm not sure.
It would be pretty
disruptive to the ecosystem.
OK, so question-- we've
talked about what happens here
from the perspective
of full nodes,
and from the
perspective of miners.
What happens from the
perspective of people
with wallets who
might be running SPV?
What do we think?
Depends on which node
they're connected to.
So one problem with SPV is
that they don't actually
get the blocks.
So they don't actually
validate blocks.
All they validate
is proof of work.
Some changes that
make a block invalid
might show up in the header.
But a lot of changes that
might make a block invalid,
or new blocks valid, don't
show up in the header.
So given what we've learned
about how SPV works,
what happens when
there's a fork?
So let's go back and take a
look at what SPV wallets see.
They see the block headers.
You have to download
all the headers, which
includes the nines
for the proof of work,
the Merkle root for the
transaction, timestamp,
stuff like that.
They also get Merkle
paths for the transactions
that they've told the node
they're interested in.
So what would happen if there
were a soft work or hard fork?
What would happen to an SPV?
They don't really have
a say in the situation.
They aren't really
participating in validation.
They're not
participating in mining.
And they're kind of at
the mercy of whatever
node that they are talking to.
And, in fact, if they try
to talk to multiple nodes,
they might get multiple
different answers.
And they don't really know which
answer is the right answer.
And this could get really
tricky and complicated.
Now, I think probably
it's fair to say
that the majority of the Bitcoin
ecosystem, in terms of users,
actually does not run
their own full nodes.
They interact with
the Bitcoin network,
at best, through SPV, and
at worst through a trusted
third party like Coinbase.
So what does the ecosystem
have to say or do about
whether or not forks are
accepted or not accepted?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They don't
really have to.
NEHA NARULA: They don't
really have a say.
They kind of I would say at
like a meta level, in that users
can pressure Coinbase to start
following Bitcoin Cash which
is a hard fork of bitcoin.
They kind of have a say
at an economic level,
in that if Coinbase starts
accepting Bitcoin Cash,
then the price of
Bitcoin Cash will go up.
And so that's kind
of a big deal.
But in terms of like
a protocol level,
in terms of accepting or
rejecting transactions,
they don't really have
a say because they
can't see enough to
determine whether or not
they're interested in following
a fork or not following a fork.
In fact, it's even
worse than that.
There were multiple
situations where
we ended up with two chains.
So an SPV wallet might think
that they received money
on one chain, and they
didn't receive money
on the other chain.
So very bad things can happen
to wallets and to SPV clients
during a fork.
And it's incredibly disruptive.
And people who create software
on the behalf of users--
so not even running SPV,
but like the Coinbase's
of the world, and the
exchanges of the world--
they have to do a
fair amount of work
to make sure that they aren't
going to lose users' money when
there's a fork.
And the exchanges, and the
Coinbase's of the world,
have screwed this
up in the past.
There's been money lost.
There are ways to
safely design your fork
so that it's less
likely that wallets
will do the wrong thing.
But I think we're kind
of just figuring out how
to really do that effectively.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yeah, so this
is kind of pretty bad,
because if Bitcoin
is really going
to undergo a hard
fork or soft fork,
everybody is paying attention.
If Ethereum is going to do it,
everyone's paying attention.
But there's so many
altcoins out there.
And, yeah, there's
so much opportunity
for people to take advantage
of the disarray that
happens when a fork happens.
So I think we're right in the
middle of trying to figure out
best practices for handling
forks safely, and also,
giving users some way of
choosing what side of a fork
that they want, because
there's this sort of thought
that eventually there will
be economic pressure to--
for a long time, people thought
that if Bitcoin hard forked,
one side would win, and the
other side would go to zero.
And now, we've seen that
that is absolutely not true.
In fact, when
Bitcoin hard forked,
sometimes the total market cap
of one side plus the other side
is bigger than the total market
cap of what Bitcoin used to be.
So money is literally
created out of nowhere.
So hard forking
is very lucrative.
It literally gives every
Bitcoin user more money.
So if you own Bitcoin
within the past--
like, if you owned
Bitcoin a year ago,
you probably have like
four other coins right now.
I don't know.
You should go sell them,
or sell the Bitcoin,
and buy the other coins,
or whatever you want to do.
But the point is,
you have more money
than you might have
even known that you had,
because someone has
done these forks.
Don't even like get
started about the tax
consequences of this.
It's very confusing,
extraordinarily confusing.
And people are trying to
figure out what to do,
because you didn't
ask for this fork.
Like, I as a holder
of Bitcoin, didn't
decide that I wanted
Bitcoin Cash to be a thing.
I didn't accept Bitcoin Cash.
But now, the same private keys I
used to control my Bitcoin also
control the same
amount of Bitcoin Cash.
It's kind of crazy.
Let's talk about
forks in practice.
So soft forks in
practice-- there
have been lots of soft forks.
Soft forks are very useful.
Soft forks are helpful.
This is the major way that
people upgrade software.
And, again, the
way that they do it
is they try to make sure
95%, or some huge majority
of the miners, are on board.
And that way, it's sort
of like as non-disruptive
to the ecosystem as possible.
So pay to script
has was a soft fork.
The introduction of
Segwit was a soft fork.
In operation, check
sequence verify
was added as a soft fork.
So that's kind of why they're
all these like unused ops
out there.
In case we want to use one
of them for something new,
we can do that with a soft fork.
Hard forks in practice--
there's lots of new Bitcoins,
Bitcoin Cash, Gold, Diamond,
like I said.
Ethereum went through a
really interesting hard fork.
And there's some
cryptocurrencies that actually
hard fork quite frequently.
For instance, I learned
the Monero hard forks
about every six months.
Vertcoin, how many hard
forks have you guys done?
Three?
Three hard forks.
So, despite the way that
I said that hard forks are
very disruptive, if you can
get all the nodes to upgrade,
it's not really a big problem.
So for cryptocurrencies where
the nodes are really well
connected, or they auto
update, or things like that,
hard forks are much
less disruptive.
So let's talk about the
Ethereum hard fork for a moment.
So this happened two years ago--
a year ago?
I can't remember when this
happened, two years ago,
I think, almost.
And so what happened
was we haven't
talked a lot about
Ethereum, so we'll
be coming to explain Ethereum
in much greater detail.
But the point is Ethereum
had a smart contract
which had a bug in it.
And someone hacked the contract,
and started siphoning off ether
from the contract.
So the Ethereum team all
got together, and decided,
we're going to
rectify this wrong.
Now, rectifying the wrong--
I mean, I already
said it's a hard fork.
But why is rectifying this wrong
a hard fork not a soft fork?
AUDIENCE: Because you
want to change history.
NEHA NARULA: Because you
That's an interesting
way of putting it.
And the way that
we change history
is not by actually going back
in time and editing history,
unless you are
Accenture I guess,
which creates
editable blockchains.
But the way that
we edit history,
is we add something to
the blockchain which
indicates that we're going to
undo, or change, or rollback
or somehow create
an operation, that
does something that
effectively undoes
what happened in the past.
So the Ethereum
developer got together.
And they originally tried to do
this as a soft fork, actually.
So it could have
been a soft fork.
And the way that the soft
work would have worked
is that it just
would have ignored
all of the transactions
that were sort of--
I can't remember
exactly how it worked.
But, basically, the
general idea was, ignore
all of the transactions that
might spend the hacker's money.
Ignore the transaction
where people gave money
to the hacker, what ultimately
became the hacker, which
is a new rule.
Now, you're shrinking the
set of acceptable blocks.
And the problem
was they realized
that if they did this
as a soft fork, then
they were inadvertently
creating an attack
vector, because people
could now spam the network
and potentially waste the
resources of the miners--
very challenging to do soft
forks and hard forks correctly.
So they decided,
OK, you know what?
We're just going to
do it as a hard fork.
When this block comes
about, block 1,920,000,
we are going to simply
transfer around 12 million
either from the hacker's
account into this other account,
this other contract, which is
going to give the money back,
where people can
reclaim their money.
So literally just
hardcoded in this transfer.
85% of the hash power in
Ethereum went along with it.
So that means 15% didn't.
And that means that there
are two currencies now.
There is Ethereum,
and Ethereum Classic.
And they persist to this
day, almost two years later.
And when I looked this
morning, it was about a 30 to 1
ratio between Ethereum
and Ethereum Classic.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So Ethereum
Classic says,
we are not OK with you
guys undoing this hack.
NEHA NARULA: Exactly,
so Ethereum Classic
says, we're not messing with
people's accounts like that.
No, no, no.
What happened happened,
fair and square.
We are not changing history.
And so in Ethereum Classic,
the hacker has money.
On Ethereum, the hacker
does not have money.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
one specific contract.
So the argument is we shouldn't
be fixing people's mistakes.
They should learn--
Was this analogous
to the Parity?
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
So here they decided,
there was a bug
in someone's smart contract.
It was exploited.
We're going to give
people their money back.
This happened again
with a different type
of smart contract in a different
way a couple months ago.
And they decided-- well, they
could still decide to do it.
But so far, they decided not
to give everyone's money back.
So there's about 90 million
or something dollars
worth of ether that's locked
up in these contracts,
due to a bug.
And in the case of the DAO,
they decided, let's do it.
In the case of this Parity bug,
they decided, let's not do it.
And if you talk to the
Ethereum Foundation people,
they'll talk about governance.
And they'll say, well, we
feel like this made sense
for these reasons.
But this doesn't make
sense for these reasons.
But it's still it's
a set of people
getting together and
deciding whether or not
to give money back.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: No, it's not
the Ethereum Foundation.
The Ethereum Foundation was
not a fan of Ethereum Classic.
It's a separate group of people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: No, actually,
so it turned out,
interestingly enough--
and this was something
that I saw at a
conference that looked
into who were the
contributors to all
of these different
forks, when trying
to understand governance?
It actually turns out that
no one from the Ethereum
Foundation works on
Ethereum Classic.
And no one who used
to work on Bitcoin
works on Bitcoin Cash,
Gold, or Diamond.
So it's entirely
new sets of people.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The former lead
developer of Bitcoin core
is working on Bitcoin Cash.
NEHA NARULA: He's not actually.
You're talking about
Gavin Andreessen?
Yeah, I don't think he actually
makes commits to Bitcoin Cash.
AUDIENCE: In a
general sense, he's
contributing on GitHub,
not specifically
to any implementations.
But to protocol,
block-level exchanges.
NEHA NARULA: Interesting.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: It
depends on how you
define contribute, certainly.
This is a really interesting
example of a hard fork.
In summary, just
to wrap up here,
forks are extremely challenging.
Upgrading software in
decentralized cryptocurrencies
is extremely challenging.
And so the lesson that I want
you to take from this is,
unless you need what a
decentralized cryptocurrency
has to offer, you will probably
be better off not using
a decentralized cryptocurrency.
They are very hard to update.
They're very hard to upgrade.
There are frequently bugs.
And so I think that forks and
the challenges around forks
are an excellent reason not to
do this when you don't have to.
And also, what's really
interesting, I think,
is that your traditional
consensus systems
don't address this
problem at all,
because your traditional
distributed consensus
systems don't have any
notion of what nodes
are going to find
valid, or not valid,
or changing the
rules of validity.
And so these
problems really only
arise when you start
to have these validity
rules that you're
dealing with, and you
have nodes that might
take one set of rules,
and nodes that might take
another set of rules.
The consensus mechanism
here ultimately
becomes irrelevant if you
don't agree with the validity
of the blocks.
It doesn't matter that
a majority of hash power
said that this is
the blockchain.
It doesn't matter if
a majority of signers
say this is the blockchain.
If you don't agree that the
things in that blockchain
are valid, you're
going to ignore that.
Majority be damned.
So it's very different
than distributed consensus.
Okay, and so real quick,
last thing...
on Wednesday we will have another guest
lecturer. Her name is Sharon Goldberg.
She's a professor at Boston University
and she's worked on a lot of really
interesting things. In particular,
something really cool that she's worked
on is using the peer-to-peer network to
create attacks in Bitcoin, and then very
recently she nor co-authors released a
paper on peer-to-peer network attacks in
Ethereum. And so she's gonna be here
to talk about the peer-to-peer networks
behind these things and to share some of
the research that she's done.